-♪ Jinx, J-J-J-Jinx Challenge ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
Tariq and I are a team,
alright,
and we'll be playing against
Russell and Ciara.
Now, in this game,
we test just how strong
your connection is
to your teammate.
-I'm talking to you already
right now.
-Yep, I know.
I can hear you, buddy.
-Mm.
-I agree.
-[ Laughs ]
-You can take turns
getting a category
that will appear on the screen,
and then you'll make eye contact
with your teammate,
count to three,
and both say something in that
category at the same time.
If you say the same thing,
it's a jinx,
and you get a point.
If you don't say the same thing,
the other team has a chance
to steal.
Make sense?
-Alright. Got it. Ready.
-Got it. Let's go.
-Alright.
What is the first category?
Menu item at an Italian
restaurant.
Ready? Oh, man.
Ready?
1, 2, 3.
-1, 2, 3.
-Spaghetti and meatballs.
-Pasta!
Oh, it was kinda --
But no jinx.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, cool.
-Usually, you don't see pasta
on the menu.
It's usually a little bit more
descriptive.
-Okay. Well, you know.
-Okay. [ Chuckles ]
-You guys get a chance to steal.
-We got this. Let's go.
-You got this? Alright.
Menu item at an Italian
restaurant.
[ Laughs ]
-You counting?
-Waiting for the count, right?
-No, you count. You count.
I thought you guys were gonna
propose again.
Dear God.
-Well, I did, though.
-Here we go. Ready?
-I'll count. Ready?
3, 2, 1.
-Lasagna.
[ Ding! ]
-Oh, come on!
[ Laughs ]
-Great.
Okay, okay. Okay.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Well played.
-That was good stuff.
Alright, it's time for
the next category.
Russell, Ciara, you're up.
What is their category?
Word that rhymes with "dog."
-Ooh. Okay.
-Ready?
-Yep.
-3, 2, 1.
-Hog.
-Fog.
-Awwww!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Buzzer ]
We got this, buddy.
-Dang! I thought about that one.
-We've got this.
Now, what is it?
Word that rhymes with "dog."
One of the best --
You rhyme with everything.
But rhyme with "dog," right?
-Yeah.
-Uh-huh.
-[ Laughs ]
-Rhyme with "dog." Here we go.
I can only think
of one thing right now.
Ready?
-1, 2, 3.
Fog!
-Frog!
[ Buzzer ]
Was so close.
-Ooh.
-Alright. You get a chance
to steal it back.
-Ready? 3, 2, 1.
Log.
-Smog.
[ Laughs ]
-Ugh.
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Do we have one?
-Oh, man.
-I know. We're kind of
running out of words.
-Oh, okay, yeah, yeah.
-Okay.
-I got one.
-Mm-hmm.
-You're communicating
with me now?
-Yes.
-Is it words that rhyme with
"dog"?
-Yes!
♪♪
Yes, because we're running out
of words.
-We're running out of words.
And it rhymes with "dog."
-Yes. Come on. Just fire off.
Let's go.
-Wait. Okay. Hold on. Wait.
[ Drumroll ]
♪♪
-10, 9, 8 --
Jaw!
-What?
What do you mean, 10, 9, 8?
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
-We need a new category.
-We burn that category.
So that category is done.
No one gets points for that.
Here we go.
Tariq, it is our turn again.
What is the next category?
Number between 1 and 10.
-Ooh, okay.
Easy.
-This is easy.
-This is easy, dude.
-Yes. It is.
-Ready?
-Let's just keep it simple.
-Let's keep it simple, man.
-Yes.
-Don't mess. Don't mess.
-K-I-S-S.
-Okay.
-So it's between 1 in 10.
-Keep it simple. 11. 11.
-Between 1 and 10.
-Yeah, okay.
-You can't say 1,
you can't say 10.
-Correct.
-Yep.
3, 2, 1.
-1, 2, 3.
5.
-7.
-What? What?!
[ Laughing ] What?!
-5?! 5 is not simple!
-It's between!
-5 is not simple!
-It's between 1 and 10!
-7! We always --
We go 1. We go 10.
-Lucky 7! Lucky 7!
-5 in the middle!
-Come on. You roll the dice!
Lucky 7?
-Lucky 7? Come on, man!
-Lucky 7. 5!
Who's yelling for 5
at the craps table?
5.
-Come on. Come on.
-Holy moly!
-Our turn. It's our turn.
-You know, when you've been
together for --
Jimmy, when you've been together
for a long time,
you know, you kind of start --
your brains start thinking
alike,
so I really have a feeling
I'm gonna get this one right.
I just have a feeling
I'm gonna get it right.
-She better get this one right.
-Let's go. Let's go.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Ready? Are you counting?
You counting?
-Yeah. I'm counting.
3, 2, 1.
3!
-3!
-Yes.
[ Ding! ]
-3. 3 is the number.
Not 7. Not 5 -- 3.
-3!
-Alright.
Let's do another one here.
[ DJ air horn honks ]
Ooh, you know what that sound
means.
It's time for the final round.
The first team to jinx
gets 1,000 points
and wins the game.
-Ooh! Okay, let's go.
-Ciara, Russell,
since you're a guest,
you have the honor of starting
the final round.
What is the category?
Something you yell
when you're angry.
-Ooh!
-Alright, ready?
-Okay.
-You counting?
-I'll count.
3, 2, 1.
-[Bleep]
-Aw!
-Ahhh!
[ Buzzer ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Wait, wait, wait.
-We got this! For the win, dude!
-Okay. Come on.
-Let's go for it.
-Come on. you ready?
-You know what I'm saying, dude?
-Yeah.
-You ready for this, man?
-[ Laughs ]
-'Cause you know what?
I've earned this.
I'm angry.
-Okay. Come on.
-1, 2, 3!
-[Bleep]
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-My guests are
Russell Wilson, Ciara.
Tariq, Russell, and Ciara
are hosting
a vaccination awareness special.
"Roll Up Your Sleeves,"
Sunday night at 7:00 p.m.
here on NBC.